Một vinh có con hậu glấp sảo, tối hiểu trường trường chân chung học cơ sử ở vẻ ăn nhìn tình sợ giấm thách thấp khi ý kiến thực cấp tế bột TV.
Anh nở về ủ, ở sát thằng dưỡng, bệnh tăng chương, cơ con đàn học glấp sảo á, chung chung học cơ sử thằng dưỡng phần anh.
Chung của có phụ quyết đầu năm sau vên chung nghiệp lấp sảo á, có vật độc đó có bệnh bột TV cho lấp họ.
Vì con sát, thời lấp đã có TV rồi, nên anh ủ thắc mắt, thì được sau vên chung nghiệp chán rời rằng chức TV đó sẽ được chuyển lên lấp chính,
cho rằng TV tạch lấp là sốc ui tức lấp đó có bột tăng, điều có tháo, bốc vý chuyển đi chỗ khác,
nhà chung về có sát nhận và ý kiến đồng ý của các vui tình hộ, lửa chừng lắm TV cho phóng sinh ngờ chung,
thì vẫn vật độc tăng chương. Mặc suy vậy, anh ủ vẫn đồng cóp diện vật độc bột TV là hai chăm tảm lắm lần đồng,
chuyển vào tay khoản của giáo về chung nghiệp. Thế nhìn sợ đau, phong anh mới tạm thẳng mời sau vên chung nghiệp,
phóng phy vật độc độc có TV là hai chung cả lấp, chú con anh ủ, anh ủ cho rằng con mình bị kỳ tình,
phần biệt đủ sử, điều này khiến cho bệnh sất bôn anh hưởng đi tâm lý,
tôi không này anh ủ còn nhận được tính tiến nhắn râu, tư ta khoản tay với bạn nhận được chau là hiểu chung chung cho mọt cơ tăng dân,
vưới lệ lệ lệ ra ra, thích thức sau đó anh này đã hủy đến thư khiu nạn lên phong só sốc voda tạo,
vui bán ninh dân viện thánh dân, sử dụng voda tạo nghe ăn,
thông tin trên đã kinh dưới lệ lệ lệ sốt sau.